أصدرت إحدى الشركات التي تعمل على كوكتيل الأجسام المضادة التي يمكن نظريًا منع أو علاج عدوى الفيروس التاجي للتو بعض النتائج الجديدة الواعدة من بعض تجاربها البشرية ، انضم إلي كبير المراسلين الطبيين سي إن إن الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا الآن يخبرنا سانجاي المزيد عن هذا نعم ، لذا هذا هو تجديد لشركة ربما سمعت عنها أننا كنا نراقبها لبعض الوقت ونوع المنتج الذي نتحدث عنه هنا هو شيء يُعرف باسم الجسم المضاد أحادي النسيلة ، لذا فهو في الأساس زوجان من الأجسام المضادة التي تم العثور عليها للمساعدة في تحييد هذا الفيروس ، وجدوا أنهم يصنعون مزيجًا من هذين الأجسام المضادة وقد تم إعطاؤه للأشخاص في هذه التجارب المبكرة جدًا.جيك ، دعني أؤكد أن ما أشاركه معك لم تتم مراجعته من قبل الأقران ، إنه يأتي فقط من خلال بيان صحفي ، لذلك يتعين علينا تقديم هذه التحذيرات التي لن نتحدث عنها عادةً ، لذا فنحن في وقت مبكر لسنا في منتصف جائحة ولكن ما يظهرونه  كان ed at jake أنه في
الأشخاص الذين
ظهرت عليهم الأعراض ولكن لم يتم إدخالهم إلى المستشفى لا يحتاجون إلى
دخول المستشفى في هذه الدراسة ، يبدو أنه
يقلل
من طول الفترة الزمنية التي ظهرت عليهم الأعراض فيها
، والأهم من ذلك أنه يبدو أنه
يقلل من كمية الفيروس
في أنوفهم وأنوفهم.  الفم
وهذا أمر مهم حقًا لأن ذلك من
المحتمل أن يجعلهم أقل عدوى ،
كما يجب أن أشير إلى متوسط
الأشخاص في هذه التجربة الذين يبلغون من العمر 45 عامًا ، لذا فإ
هم في سن 45 عامًا لا يطرحون ذلك لأ
هم لا يعتبرون  السكان المعرضون للخطر ،
لذا إذا كان عمرك 45 عامًا وتمرض ،
فهل ستحصل على
هذا العلاج بالأجسام المضادة ، فربما لا
تعرف ما إذا كنت مريضًا حقًا
ربما إذا كنت شخصًا أكبر سنًا
معرضًا للخطر
ربما وهذا  حيث يجب أن تتجه الدراسة
بعد ذلك لمعرفة ما إذا كان هذا يعمل مع
الأشخاص
الذين تعرفهم معرضين لخطر الإصابة
بأمراض خطيرة ، ولكن تمامًا كما قمت
بتأطيرها ، فإن
النتائج المبكرة التي تعد بها الكثير من الأشخاص
قد تحدثوا  حول العلاج بالأجسام المضادة
كنوع من الجسر إلى
اللقاح وهذا لا يفعل شيئًا
لأنك تعلم أنه يغير الرأي حول ذلك